that really is that's really is like the
metric i use for real good food
busting ass
yeah how much i bust ass after
because really good food i'm talking
rich food you know
like we went to this restaurant here
last week had steak with peppercorn like
thick peppercorn sauce you know i'm
talking about like hollandaise almost
yeah yeah
i mean that [ __ ] me up
meat sweats meat farts
sorry just
rolling around like a sweaty bag of lard
cody is everything all right dude food
was so good so good
oh my god i think my heart rate's
increasing like [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was so hot
so good though
yeah man
we went down to herbrosa last night have
some dinner no way for what
uh just because
covet is alive and well down there i
imagine
yeah yeah yeah nobody wearing a mask
down there eh
uh it was honestly it was pretty
dead the restaurant not a lot of people
there not many where'd you go what
restaurant did you go to uh mexican
restaurant i don't remember the name
honestly i haven't had like spicy food
in a while just because you know my
[ __ ] has
acid reflux so i said [ __ ] it i'm
giving myself a little treat tonight
and i had a series of hot things and
i've never felt like
damn that amount of just like
meat sweat
like
head high
i'm like damn dude i feel like i'm like
i took an edible or something people are
talking to me at the table i'm like huh
yeah dude my dad
my dad and my mom like don't really eat
meat
like at all unless it's a special
occasion
and so we went to that restaurant
together and we both ordered that steak
with the peppercorns and the sauce and
everything he ate the whole thing
the next day he was like [ __ ] i feel
like i have a hangover
i'm [ __ ] up like actually like i have
a meat meat over whatever and so like
the
two days later we got barbecue there's
one barbecue joint in town
it's like they got a big ass pit they
smoked ribs brisket all day and it was
new year's eve so we're like that feels
like a new year's eve type
meal yeah so we got it got this tray of
every type of meat you could imagine and
brought it home
liver king and he was so scarred he
didn't eat any of the meat he ate
cornbread and beans
and we're like are you good and he was
like yeah i'm just not not doing meat
tonight
really it's all it's only meat
that's all there is here and then
there's beans and he's like i'll just
take the beans you pass the
beans yeah he was that scarred
damn bro
your dad went to sleep like having
nightmares
yeah seriously
honey are you okay you were tossing and
turning in your sleep yeah i had this
dream i was like a hot dog eating
contest and it just he's moving into
sleep
oh [ __ ]
i had this horrible dream i was a cow
yeah that i mean that sounds delicious
what happened
shout out to this cow right there
oh the cow skull yeah
shout out to the boy
you